hi I'm Erik Bosse and the introduction
of the shape-shifting squirrel to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe means that
what a more unhinged Marvel nerds
Captain Marvel might be hiding a darker
truth
specifically the mystery of which
character or characters in the MCU could
actually be a Skrull impostor there was
a fourth scroll who got away and it was
implied that these alien refugees could
be embedded everywhere some friendly
others more hostile I investigated a
similar theory recently with Nick Fury
but now let us turn to Carol Danvers in
another episode of scroll surge spoiler
warning again it may be reasonably right
they're only on what overlooked clues in
the Captain Marvel movie could point to
the possibility that Carol Danvers might
be a squirrel but before I dive into
evidence
I should explain that Skrull can copy a
life-forms appearance down to a DNA
level but in addition to that due to
advanced girl technology some Scrolls
can also imitate their targets powers
and abilities varieties known as super
Skrulls or war Skrulls had been known to
replicate superheroes and in the Secret
Invasion comic storyline physically
enhanced individuals like Spider Woman
Jessica drew were revealed to have been
a scroll in disguise the whole time the
whole time so it is possible that
super-powered individuals not just
seemingly trustworthy government
officials can also be liars
so as Captain Marvel scroll clue 1 where
has she been for 23 years also doesn't
impossible to answer question count as
evidence well if you believe in
conspiracy theories it sure does at the
end of Captain Marvel we learned that
Carol Danvers departed Earth in 1995
joining the scroll in their search for a
new homeworld in the movies post credits
scene she returns to Earth in 2018
shortly after the events of Avengers
infinity war and a lot of things gonna
happen in 23 years folks especially when
your best friends are shape shifters one
question that we asked with Nick Fury
was why didn't he page Captain Marvel
for help during any of the other past
emergencies on earth when the stakes
seemed equally dire in apocalyptic well
could it be possible that Nick Fury did
actually page Captain Marvel during each
of those events but just Captain Marvel
never responded what's this
Hellmouth open / New York please help
sorry busy stealing others identities
this is a phone charger I don't have a
pager I'm not 50 maybe captain marvel
only returns to Earth after Thanos to
snap when Earth would be weakened but
then again after Athena's to snap every
alien race in Planet would be 50% weaker
caroler scroll she would be just as
freaked out as anyone else and Marvel's
captive are of a prelude comic indicated
that Nick Fury still trusted Captain
Marvel as late as a couple years before
Infinity Ward's so for another
explanation let's look at clue number
two Carole is closer with the Skrulls
than anyone compared to every other
character we know so far in the MCU no
one's still alive has proven to have a
more intimate relationship with the
scroll than Captain Marvel early on the
Skrulls scanned Carole's memories she
later tells fury that the one way to
prove that you're not a scroll is to
share a memory or secret about yourself
that would be impossible for the scrolls
to mimic but if they had access to all
of her memories
Oliver subconsciousness details that she
herself didn't fully understand this
Skrull should be able to replicate those
details as well
hero proved the fury that she was real
by photon blasting a jukebox saying the
scroll couldn't do that but as I pointed
out from these Secret Invasion comics
some scroll absolutely can copy powers
actually in Secret Invasion Spider Woman
is revealed to be the scroll queen
veranke as the younger princess veranke
was out casted for her obsession with
ancient scroll prophecies preaching a
coming wave of devastation and the need
to take a world of blue as their new
home she was ignored but then Galactus
showed up and destroyed the Skrull
throneworld propelling Bucky to the
throne with earth becoming the world of
blue that the scrolls see as their
prophecy forever home now in Captain
Marvel will Talos and his crew don't
appear to be driven by any dogmatic
agenda but it is interesting that the
movie gave him a daughter her name is
never revealed but there is a curious
moment at the end when the daughter
plays uno with Monica Rambeau Monica
complements their eyes telling the
scroll daughter don't ever change your
eyes Laer lee Marvel is setting up
Monica to one day join the MCU herself
as the superhero photon or pulsar
spectrum whatever name they use would it
be that shocking if they had a future in
mind for this scroll daughter as well
perhaps the most famous female Skrull
character veranke
now this girl's family is on good terms
with Kat
marvel and earth right now but one
theory for the next phase of Marvel
films is that Galactus could be the next
arch villain he's now a Marvel Studios
property once again thanks to the Disney
Foxx merger and Marvel head Kevin Feige
revealed that he was part of Galactus
movie cameo negotiations for other
projects to be seen Vice cameo lactis
cameo in there we helped him get in the
Infinity Gauntlet comics go actus is one
of the cosmic entities because real
pissed off at Thanos after the snap so
maybe in the movies the snap could
awaken Galactus now in-game might be too
soon for a Glac disappearance since it
was written and shot before the Disney
Fox merger was finalized but maybe a
post-credits scene to end game or a
future phase for film Galactus having
destroyed the Skrull planet could be the
event that radicalizes a number of
Scrolls making them desperate for a new
home and leading a member of the younger
scroll generation to take extreme
measures like changing her eyes to those
of a longtime human companion and posing
as that human to infiltrate earth and
Earth's Mightiest Heroes now if Marvel
Studios has swapped in Captain Marvel
for the Spider Woman Secret Invasion
role I also think of interest in game
might be too soon to reveal his
bombshell but actually let's look at
Carol Danvers and the limited in-game
footage that we've seen when Captain
Marvel returns to Earth
she's definitely changed she's got a new
hairstyle more golden lining on her suit
and she demands intensely wears fury and
that's after creeping up behind the
Avengers no greeting whatsoever and like
she's still learning how to human sure
maybe 23 years of space adventures
changes a person and the urgency of this
moment leaves no time for pleasantries
or she's the lyin sack scroll just
remember that brie Larson shot her
scenes for Avengers in-game before
production started for Captain Marvel so
there may be some inconsistencies and
larsa's performances between the two
movies and maybe that is by design maybe
the before-and-after Carol Danvers is is
are two different individuals look look
I know if Captain Marvel ends up being a
major Buttkicker against Thanos and all
of her binary glory revealing her to be
a scroll and posture later on could
strip the character of her uniqueness
but just something to keep in mind let's
say Captain Marvel into
before the final act of endgame like
she's a big character just not a
decisive one and then other characters
end up going on to save the day that
honestly looks likely for this story we
would now have a very intriguing
possible explanation for why that
version of Captain Marvel is less of a
closer cuz maybe she is scroll which
Marvel characters should we investigate
next in this scroll Sarge comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at a boss let's
check out my live comedy show in l.a
darkest timeline comedy mix show April
5th oh and if you're into sci-fi and
superheroes check out the channel space
space for new videos every Saturday like
new rock star space days the ants to
tackle all the geek covers has to offer
they break down the ethical themes of
your favorite sci-fi films they create
time-lapse art fusions of classic comic
book characters and more their latest
video is a parody of each and hollywood
story but instead of covering
celebrities it's centered on the
Wolverine this is one or two story that
you haven't seen before as it matches a
Wolverine with secreta snowman and
they're just starting out so be sure to
click on the link in the description box
and check them out and subscribe yeah be
sure to comment that new Rockstar sent
you thank you for watching and no I am
NOT a scroll but I guess I wouldn't tell
you if it was one
[Music]